what i think is interesting about that
what's interesting about obama because
it's a very interesting study
is that presidents are controlled in
very different ways right
you know presidents can be controlled by
different factors
power factions within washington and
right you know i think one of the
reasons that uh
obama was maybe you know he had a very
close relationship with john brennan he
was a cia director
and obama was very close with john
brennan and obama was very
you know um you know i think uh
malleable
to the extent that you know the cia and
i've had cia agents on my show john
kiriyaku a guy who went to jail for
exposing
torture was saying that like you know
you get into the oval office all of a
sudden you're having the presidential
daily briefing every day and the
intelligence people come in and they go
listen man i mean we're there's going to
be a terrorist attack on your watch if
you don't do x y and z
they go we have you know the quote they
call it like blue book information which
is five levels above top secret and they
go like
hey man a guy in uh a guy in iran in a
cafe
said he's blown everything up next week
and you know i mean it's the same thing
as parlor you don't know if it's true or
not
but now the president's making decision
on usually
a lot of uncorroborated intelligence
that goes into a
presentation for the president where
you're just terrified every day and you
don't want a terrorist attack on your
watch
now so why are they getting all the
information because
a lot of the people in washington have
an interest in perpetual constant
ongoing warfare
and there's a lot of financial gain to
be had from that so they're sneaking
their information
into the presentations that are going to
the president and then the president is
now behaving and going
i don't want a bomb going off we got to
do what we got to do and
whatever version of that happens that is
really kind of what is happening whereas
the presidents are being controlled by
forces that are
outside of the political sphere but very
much still
in it and they have a lot of that's what
the deep state is you know trump
there's a lot of ridiculing trump of
gone the deep state doesn't exist
it absolutely exists there's been books
about it written by liberal journalists
the deep state is only a term for
unelected largely power factions in
washington dc
that outlive any presidential
administration these are people that
might work at the state department
they might work at the defense
department uh these are people that are
not always working officially in any
government capacity
they might be private companies they
might be
uh military contractors they might be
people of boeing or raytheon or general
dynamics
and they constitute a
group of people that trump kind of
called the swamp but trump had really no
interest in draining the swamp but it
was he articulated
these things and this is what it is you
have a lot of interested parties
that have budgets that they want big
budgets everybody wants a budget in
washington whether you know what it is
they want money
um and these are the people who who
really control press so this idea that
the president is the bln doll
has got to be smashed which is why the
horse race model of politics and being
like is it right wing is it left wing is
it
what team am i on and what color am i
wearing it's very simplistic but the
reality is
this is an empire it's past its peak
we're in trouble the united states is an
empire speaker yeah
i mean that's just his you could prove
that case in court
well let's let's go to court right now
but i do love the
the more complex idea that there's just
human beings
who create power and seek ways to attain
that power through different ways
if you have uh barack obama or george
bush
or donald trump there's different attack
vectors
correct different ways to obtain that
power and then you can use that to
leverage and
it probably doesn't have to be just in
washington dc
uh there's people who crave power for
all over the world
of course not in but where we are now in
los angeles these people are all good
uh l.a studio executive from what i
understand they treat everyone
fairly and and they're nice but
i think he sees the bad guys but out
here in l.a west coast
everyone's lovely
you